joining us now former Speaker of the
House n Gingrich Fox News contributor as
well new uh you have a list too of
things that Biden should talk about
tonight but won't what did I
miss you're right on target I think he
first of all should withhold the100
million until all the hostages are
released and let's not kid ourselves if
Hamas is still alive Hamas is going to
get the money so the the destruction of
Hamas the release of the hostages should
predate any American Aid uh to Gaza
second he ought to be honest about
Iran's role in all this uh the Biden
policy enriched the Iranian dictatorship
made it more possible for it to support
terrorism else everywhere uh and you
know to confirm he ought to confront
gutter about the fact that they have the
Hamas leaders who are still sitting
right there in very comfortable places
with no threats he should in fact say
openly we support Israel in the total
Destruction of Hamas when he said that
on the plane on the way back about the
other team it was sickening as it could
implies some there's two teams the
Israelis and the terrorists no they're
not two teams they're civilization and
there are people who be had babies let's
be let's be clear here uh there's not a
team game here there's a horrifying evil
force that needs to be destroyed uh
frankly before we give money to to
Ukraine and I support helping Ukraine uh
one they ought to give them the most
advanced tactical missiles which they
have refuse to do uh two we should have
a complete audit I don't see any reason
why we're paying the the Ukrainian Civil
Service why we're providing basically
social welfare um that that's nutty that
that sort of the Great Society goes to
Ukraine uh so I think that I'd be very
careful
about combining the
two I think new one of the the most
obvious disconnects here for the
American people is that we are simply
refusing to do what is necessary on our
border and so millions and millions of
people have come in including a lot from
countries that sponsor terrorism we
don't know what where they are we don't
know what they're doing maybe some of
them are just working but the point is
we're we're spending hundreds of
billions of dollars overseas yet our own
country slowly but surely is completely
being overrun in certain parts of the
country especially by
migrants look I think it would be
perfectly reasonable for the republicans
in Congress to include a profound change
in our border policy uh as part of any
package and just say we're not going to
go forward unless we get this worked out
you have I think the worst
Administration since Buchanan who
presided just before the Civil War and
maybe even beginning to be worse than
Buchanan uh it is appalling how bad this
Administration is in every way whether
it's controlling the Border stopping
fenel go down the list uh this is a very
dangerous very bad government yeah I I I
wouldn't give them any money because I
don't trust them and I I think they I
think until our own border is secure I
don't think any of this makes a lot of
sense but new I mentioned this a moment
ago the White House post posted this
photo to Instagram last night with the
faces of our special operators
revealed so n this put a bounty on the
head heads of these men I want to know
who the heck is getting fired for this
or is this just like the the withdrawal
from Afghanistan no one ever loses their
job no one ever apologizes there is zero
accountability for failure
zero right well you know the answer to
that this this is an utterly incompetent
Administration which lies every single
day uh and which has frankly has no
sense of respect for the American
Military uh and I think that it's pretty
clear uh that this was just a photo up I
mean the whole trip when you look at it
and you think about the fact that
nothing really good came out of it uh
was an was I think a pathetic effort at
proing up Biden for reelection and if
anything I think it'll leave him weaker
as people think deeply about how many
different ways the Biden Administration
has strengthened terrorism strengthened
Iran weakened our allies uh and
basically fail to do its
job new great to see you tonight thank
you so much